[Applause] now boil it's a three-on-one for
the Hawks to Win It boil Kinski Kinski boil
and he couldn't get a shot away now morisi in
alone on morazzi morisi stopped by morazzi Neer
Rider backhand save mazic boiler snaking his
way through Center and bringing it back into
the Blackhawks Zone oh my goodness what
a play by Lucas reel to create that three
onone and boila I don't think he was expecting
it to come back to him Bard now Main Street he
scores it's [Applause] over Conor Bard's second
goal of the game he bookends this one a first
buriad ice breaker and an overtime game winner
and another solid celebration afterward turns
to the crowd big smile for Conor Bard
what a rush up the ice all by himself
splits the two players and beats one of the
best goendale league glov side the deception
the speed unbelievable drag release right
there he just gets it on the toe it might
have taken a little redirection off the stick
and gets by huk love that big smile for Conor
badar it's over it's over what an effort oh
my gosh what an effort you know again it it
was consistency tears of joy wow Conor bringing
the fan to tears at 18 won't be the last time